gut mag
das erste olympia wochenende ist um ein
aufregendes und ziemlich aufregendes es
ging schon los mit mit großen problemen
für ein paar deutsche sportler erzähl
mal was los war und wie jetzt die lage
ist ja am samstag war es als der
deutsche olympische sportbund alarm
geschlagen hat dann drei seiner sportler
die von ihr betreut werden schwer zu
leiden haben oder den charaktere
bedingungen die hotelzimmer seien nicht
standesgemäß groß die hygiene sei nicht
gewährleistet es gab probleme mit dem
essen auch die tests was die pcr testung
die jeden tag vorgeschrieben ist das sei
nicht so zuverlässig alles abgenommen
worden wie man es hätte erwarten können
und ja eric frenzel hat sich jetzt
gestern selbst gefilmt mit einer
videobotschaft aus seinem quarantäne
hotel gemeldet es geht ihm besser erst
umgezogen theres weber ist umgezogen
roland seeger eiskunstläufer hat ein
bisschen equipment bekommen von der
alpha der nationalmannschaft kann auch
auf dem ergometer arbeiten kann sich
vorbereiten
aber ich glaube die klage hat
deutschland erreicht und hat ein
bisschen schlaglicht darauf geworfen
unter welchen bedingungen diese
olympische wieder stattfinden wir haben
auch das ioc erreicht muss man sagen
relativ deutlich reagiert gestern als
sie sagten es dürfte kein stein auf dem
anderen bleiben
er hat christophe duby gesagt
exekutivdirektor vom ioc den kennt man
nun wirklich nicht als scharfen kritiker
dessen was die chinesen hier so in den
letzten jahren auf die beine gestellt
oder vorbereitet haben insofern war das
schon sehr deutlich um das thema bleibt
auch weil es weiterhin auch klagen gibt
jetzt von den deutschen nicht mehr aber
eine polnische shorttrackerin hat so
eine beschreibung gegeben die den test
positiv dann wieder negativ dann wieder
positiv dann wieder negativ sie dachte
sie kommt raus dann sollte sie doch
wieder drin bleiben in der isolation und
das war die hatte die hat sagt von
horror gesprochen ja also es war richtig
historisch die hat sich gar nicht mehr
getraut aus dem fenster zu gucken dachte
sie weil sie meinte das dürfte sie nicht
also da wird schon extrem mit der psyche
gespielt der sportler und ja warum das
sein muss oder wer das zulässt die frage
ist eigentlich die spannende wie kann
das sein dass nachdem die deutschen
rodler im november geklagt haben darüber
und gesagt haben so geht es nicht und
das muss sich bessern und diese
besserung versprochen war dass sie kommt
dass es dann jetzt hier bei den spielen
doch wieder so ist und das thema ist in
dem sinne dann nicht beantwortet also
schon wenn es noch nicht beendet der
beute die korona zahlen die fallzahlen
die neuen gehört hat also corona ist
hier immer noch ein thema wird ein thema
bleiben und die sichere blase der klaus
blum ist eine wunschvorstellung aber
wird
dann doch nicht überall so durchzuhalten
sein ja schauen wir mal hoffen wir mal
dass es besser wird aber eben also ich
finde die frage wer ist dafür
verantwortlich dass das so ist und das
ist so schief gegangen werden die müsste
im prinzip beantwortet werden ist sie
noch nicht ich möchte einmal weil wir
davon sprechen dass wir jetzt das
eröffnungswochenende hinter uns haben
mal kurz etwas ins bild halten und zwar
ist das hier die offizielle publikation
der winterspiele 2022 peking 2022 wir
sehen die ausgabe vom 6 februar also
sonntag
unter tage nach der eröffnung zwei tage
nach der eröffnungsfeier wir sehen auf
dem bild auch wenn es sehr klein ist und
vielleicht gar nicht mal fotografisch
gesehen eins der besseren bilder ist
glaube ich aber trotzdem jedem klar dass
das keine wintersportler sind nur um mal
zu zeigen hier hier im medienzentrum der
olympischen spiele liegt quasi die
propaganda der chinesin frei aus hier
geht es eben darum welche botschaft
jinping mit seiner eröffnungsfeier
senden wollte in diesem in diesem
aufmacher artikel kommt hier unten nur
jinping zu wort wie gesagt offizielles
platz der winterspiele blätterdach es
gab ein schönes bezeichnendes bild auf
bei dem er zum abendessen eingeladen hat
ist dass das man nicht indem ich meine
das wäre jetzt muss mal gucken finden
wirst du schnell dass ich meine hier in
japan im original sin committee blatt
also vom organisationskomitee dann da
gibt es auch noch mal um die
eröffnungsfeier also gemeint ist das tue
er beim staatsbankett eine winterliche
wetter eine winterlandschaft eine
winterlandschaft aufgehabt aufbauen
lassen ja dass damit die zuschauer
wissen was wir damit sagen wollen das
sind alles zeitungen die hier frei
verfügbar sind für die journalisten also
nur wenn ich wieder heißt ja olympia
habe nichts mit politik zu tun
naja
das spricht für sich würde ich sagen
[Musik]
wir wollen auch über ein sportliches
thema sprechen diese woche glaube ich
ein turnier los von dem ich glaube das
ist wahrscheinlich schon nach dem was
vor vier jahren passiert ist
den ein oder anderen interessieren
könnte eishockey bei ihren rennen zuvor
das ja mit silber in vier jahren haben
die deutschen mehr erreicht als man je
hätte träumen gewagt und sie kommen
jetzt hierher mit sehr viel
selbstvertrauen sie haben eine
mannschaft beisammen die sich was
ausrechnen kann
viele legionäre aus nordamerika dürften
nicht kommen können nicht kommen dafür
haben sie andere dabei die in schweden
spielen
domenica uhr auf rtl erfahren der jetzt
in bern center in der ersten reihe ist
sie haben leute kühnhackl und reader 3
schweden legionäre sie haben ein
gespieltes spieler aus der dl sie haben
den topsturm der eisbären mit leo
pföderl und marcel noebels also sie
haben eine mannschaft die die in sicht
funktioniert die weiß auch was der
trainer will und ich bin sehr gespannt
das spiel eins wird gegen kanada gleich
sein normalerweise sagt man deutschland
kanada kanada der rekord weltmeister und
olympiasieger aber das ist ja nun kanada
oder vielleicht sogar 1 d das sind
nicht die topstars die können nicht
kommen weil die nfl ihre spieler nicht
freigegeben hat also da sind auch viele
legionäre aus der deutschen eishockey
liga dabei und die haben sich bestimmt
noch nicht so gefunden sind nicht so
eingespielt ließen das deutsche team ist
die chance und die voraussetzungen etwas
zu erreichen waren glaube ich bei
olympia noch nie so groß wie diesmal
schauen wir mal was sich daraus ergibt
und science berichten ob es dann
womöglich wieder eine medaille gibt es
dort das ziel ist schon lang
also er will er will etwas mitbringen
und das soll nicht nur die schmutzige
wäsche sein aber ich glaube nicht hatte
und er hat nicht an das maskottchen
gedacht dass hier jedem überreicht wird
er will was mitbringen und ich glaube so
wie er im tunnel ist und da wir haben ja
jetzt auch im interview im blatt er ist
sehr
dessen vertrag ausläuft
spielt die mannschaft spielt auch ein
bisschen für den trainer und man mal
gucken müssen wie es da weitergeht beim
deutschen eishockey-bund die mannschaft
würde gerne mit ihm weitermachen aber
vielleicht wird er einfach zu groß für
den erfolg und zieht ihn dann woanders
hin müssen wir mal gucken aber erstmal
muss gespielt werden wird spannend
schauen uns an wir melden uns wieder aus
danke an die kamera kindern
[Musik]